Speaker 1: You know, I've been really hopeful
that I was never again going to have to mention
the name Sherri Tenpenny to you, it's a horrible
name, not on principle, but because of who
Sherri Tenpenny is, you may or may not remember
that Sherri Tenpenny is this anti-vaccine
osteopathic physician who believes that vaccines
cause autism, who previously made all sorts
of wild statements about COVID and about vaccination.
She is back, and she is now saying that vaccinating
children, which is the next phase of getting
out of this pandemic, we got to get everybody
vaccinated or as close to everybody as possible.
We now can vaccinate five to 11 year olds
with the Pfizer vaccine.
Dr. Tenpenny, Dr. Tenpenny is back saying
that's like a late term abortion.
If you give a vaccine to a kid, it's like
a really, really, really late term abortion
now, as a reminder.
This is from a few months ago.
Here is Sherri Tenpenny saying that we really
shouldn't be afraid of COVID.
But she is spreading all sorts of horrible
lies about the vaccines to make people afraid.
Remember this?
This was months ago.
Take a look.
Speaker 4: Thinking if there is, if you can
think of any other product in any other industry
that has killed more than 5000 people stated
in the vast database.
And even if only half of those are true, 200
2500 deaths in six months of use.
And it's still full court press full steam
ahead.
So it makes one have to wonder why?
Why are we still doing this?
Why are we putting people into nursing homes
like this happened in New York and put people
with non-COVID into place?
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Tenpenny also promotes conspiracies
about 5G cell phone networks and more.
Let's take a listen to that
Speaker 2: and some of the information that
I think had been discussed in your podcast
related EMF frequencies.
That was
Speaker 4: a thought.
And I mean, because now because right now
we're all kind of hypothesizing, I mean, what
is it that's actually being transmitted that's
causing all of these things?
Is it a combination of the protein which now
we're finding has a metal attached to it?
I'm sure you've seen the pictures all over
the internet of people who've had these shots
and now they're magnetized and put a key on
their forehead.
It sticks, they can put spoons and forks all
over them and they can stick because now we
think that there's a metal piece to that.
There has been people who've long suspected
that there was some sort of an interface and
yet to be defined in the interface between
what's being injected in these shots and all
of the 5G towers.
Not proven yet, but we're trying to figure
out what is it that's being transmitted to
these unvaccinated people.
Speaker 1: So this is someone who has made
now.
I don't know about a career, but she's made
herself quite prominent as a as a sort of
a darling of the anti-vaccine and conspiracy
movement.
She's been against masks, even though we have
scientific, peer reviewed studies about the
effectiveness of masks.
She's against vaccines, she says.
The vaccines can kill you.
They can cause autoimmune disease, that some
people will die from the vaccine directly
and others are just going to get really, really
sick and get long term diseases, maybe 42
days out, maybe a year out, et cetera.
On and on and on.
Sperm quality claims, et cetera.
So now she has resurfaced at this week how
many people that we have covered ended up
at this very place the Reawaken America rally
over the weekend in San Antonio.
Michael Flynn was there.
I think Mike Pillow was there, just so many
people that we follow, we're at this absolutely
horrible event.
Right wing Pastor John Hagee did the event
at the Cornerstone Church in San Antonio,
Texas.
Here is Tenpenny saying a lot of crazy things
dangerous things, including that giving a
kid a vaccine is like an abortion.
Speaker 4: People have got to start saying
to their bosses who are require them to get
tested if they don't get a shot that you need
to start saying to them torture is illegal
in the United States of America.
Speaker 1: Now that will not work.
The advice that Tenpenny gives will not work.
Vaccine requirements are legal.
A vaccine isn't torture.
You will probably lose your job if you follow
Tenpenny advice,
Speaker 4: and you repeatedly testing me for
being noncompliant and disobedient is torture.
Speaker 1: COVID tests are not torture, either.
You're going to lose your job if you do what
she says.
Speaker 4: I think that we're going to be
writing that up and we're going to sending
it into the EEOC and we're going to start
accusing you and these policies of being torture.
Speaker 1: Now the EEOC is the Equal Employment
Opportunity Council, I think I think it's
that anyway, the idea that if you write to
them and say it's torture to test an employee
that the EEOC is going to get involved, it's
a waste of time.
Everything she says is a waste of time.
Speaker 4: Call a spade a spade.
And we know that this is murder by injection,
right?
And you're supposed to give this is sacrificing
your children.
To.
Balloch.
To battle child sacrifice.
Speaker 1: So now, as if it wasn't off the
rails before now, they bring in all of this
mark of the beast child sacrifice, weird scriptural
stuff
Speaker 4: and resurged in these final days
from the Babylonian mystery schools.
Speaker 1: Wait a second.
I thought she was here as a as an osteopathic
doctor.
What is ball have to do with that
Speaker 4: are available in the descendants
of Nimrod?
And this is what is happening.
And if you see anybody participating in this,
you need to be challenging them of what they
are doing to their spirituality and what they
are sacrificing their children to.
Hmm.
You know, I had a really good friend who said,
you know, we've sacrificed over 60 million
newborn unborn babies in an abortion.
We have multiple states in this country who
actually allow late term abortion.
Now we are doing very, very, very, very late
term abortion by killing five year olds.
Speaker 1: So she is saying, you give a five
year old the vaccine, they're going to die.
It's like an abortion.
Speaker 4: This is happening in America, people,
and it's your job to stop everybody, you know,
and wake them up and shove it in their face.
And if they defund you off of social media,
who cares
Speaker 1: if they defund you off of social
media?
This is is this a grifter or is it a sick
woman or is it both?
Speaker 4: Now it's about trying to save unborn
babies and pregnant women.
It's about the there.
Now we're actually starting a trial to give
these shots to six month olds.
This is child sacrifice.
This is the resurgence of child sacrifice
from the days of the Babylonian mystery schools,
as it said in Genesis six Genesis.
What Jesus himself said that in those final
days, it will be like, as in the days of Noah
and what were they doing, child sacrifice
and what else were they doing?
Speaker 1: It's funny because, you know, she's
presented as this great Dr. Tenpenny, but
she flips back and forth between speaking
about her supposed medical credentials and
knowledge, which are shaky versus just making
religious claims were then.
It's like, Well, so it's just it's more of
like a pastor, then it's not really.
What does it really matter that she's Dr.
Tenpenny?
If what she's talking about is Noah and the
Babylonians and all and all of these different
things.
This is a dangerous woman.
I don't exactly know what licensing she's
subject to.
It should be investigated and it should be
explored whether she actually is worthy of
that license.
But the question I really continue to come
away with is, are we talking about a grifter
here or are we talking about a sick woman?
Are we talking about a liar?
Are we talking about someone who's confused?
What is it really about?
I'm curious to hear from you